welcome to this video a beautiful mind
let me check this Roland Roland lecture
from Switzerland can I do something else
very ups maybe a bit known here or
something modern been only without any
particular knowledge always going for
the for the hard stuff ok oh really yeah
you even prevent them Bishop g4 here hmm
okay yeah it just makes some sense I
mean I don't I don't really know the
opening yeah yeah I understand yeah
the modern baloney and he goes f4 that's
not good I really don't know this
opening in any detail I mean I know some
white ideas of course but black hmm okay
see pushing e5 immediately here oh maybe
it's not
not pushing immediately I became but it
it will it will threaten at some point
you had to had to play here yeah people
who played the beam only really need
good nerves yeah the white always has
this ready-made plan with e45 and when
it hits it it hits very hard
if I've looks almost winning her if it
comes you 5u6 that's totally incorrect
but I really don't see see a move yeah
it is really not a really good opening
this is modern benoni of you if you are
not a total expert then you really get
wiped out with with those aggressive
setups yeah yeah I know it's nothing
now after ye five I can take and take d5
at least yeah but still have a pawn down
maybe I can maybe I can go c4 and 95 or
something Wow after c4 you would put
something on deform
yeah that's really just lost would like
nothing more not say nothing less if
he's totally you can just take a sixer
yep
yeah but I mean I have to play something
Bishop e3 is also not bad
there should be three Bishop g4
my spending time for whatever reason
yeah on top of everything one even has a
pond you can go to see six oh yeah not
sure how great that was but it
definitely is annoying enough
there should be three now he somehow
never wants to play that I mean maybe
he's somewhat worried that I take C 3
and E 4 but this really looks very
dangerous giving up my bishop on g7 okay
maybe I even I get some subjectivity
unbelievable
I'm ahead on the clock yeah can you
believe that this is something that
really happens in any case and here I
was far down on time yeah I mean by now
it's maybe not that clear I have some
activity at least yeah of course this is
why this is what white can do all the
time
this kind of stuff I'm I'm going to play
quickly here trying to imitate him with
activity Knight takes d5 has maybe an
idea now this was one idea of 93 cutting
off the support of the Queen on d5 if I
get to take Knight takes d5 my position
is oh wow improving considerably I
wanted to say nice that's interesting I
was a knight b5 was maybe even even more
of a problem okay where do I put this
here a night before night you see I can
take with the Queen earthing and wind we
know other stuff here check of course
yeah
the deep horns the deep horns there are
two of them they might be the problem at
the moment my knight is covering this my
rooks are not bad maybe I can with h5h
for initiate a meeting attack Age 5
Queen b6 h form I check him ok I have to
go back then
check oh man what the heck am I doing
here
oh man is this a fasten here sorry
ah how easy do I want to make it for him
yeah very very easy come on this is this
is really not fun he's really giving me
everything here and I completely
blundered away oh no is there some way
to at least play this position probably
not yummy unbelievable but I'm doing him
really unbelievable
you
okay threatening here time worried that
95 this is the most problematic thing
ninety-five
snow no play whatsoever here
I can just go 95 it's lost yeah it's
simply lost unbelievably really gave me
this game like on a silver plate yeah
and I just didn't take it black resigns
really bad why is it just like I have no
move here maybe this like that
Bishop age six and he resigned seven
okay yeah I couldn't really believe all
that I just have to pay attention yeah I
mean it's not like Bishop h6 is so easy
but this is not working
my mother will find that and she does
not really know how to play chess this
is so easy yeah I was just blundering
away this totally winning position step
by step oh it's funny he could have
taken the Queen Maat aquatic game he
could have taken the Queen I was going
here instead of d7 it yet had this just
played this channel oh what a game
no and of course I was totally lost out
of the opening around yet it already
gets gets to dramatic proportions damn
and you could have just taken the Queen
in one move check instead it went to
this we went with this Bishop h6 no wins
instead I'm check said that blunder
blunder everything
wow what a game wow thanks for watching